We're entering a moment of existential questioning
that I don't think either of us have seen in our lifetime.
(upbeat music)
What am I here to do?
What should I do with my life?
If these are questions, you find yourself asking yourself,
then you're in the right place at the right time.
Because my guest today has essentially devoted his life
to helping people answer these very important questions.
His name is Jonathan Fields.
And in addition to being a dear friend,
a mentor to me personally,
a dad and author of many, a best-selling book,
the man behind the wonderful,
Good Life project Podcast and Community
and maker of many other beautiful things.
Jonathan holds this core belief that we all have
an innate impulse or imprint for
work that makes us come alive.
All of us have this and over many years spent studying this
thinking deeply about this writing about this has divined,
an evidence-based method for helping people discover it.
It is this terrain that today we tread,
a fascinating conversation that will no doubt leave you
inspired to dig deeper, which you should all do
by picking up his brand new stunning book.
It's called Sparked.
I endured this beautiful man for reasons
you will soon discover.
So let us not teary.
Please hit that subscribe button hit the notification bell.
And without further ado, this is me and Jonathan Fields.
So good to see you.
You too.
Long overdue, I think the last time I saw you was
at Mel Robin's house in.
Vermont.
Vermont's.
Yeah.
When was that, it was pre COVID.
Certain yeah, but I think it was like
two and a half years ago.
Well, it was spring, I think, right.
It was probably spring.
So probably going on like, yeah,
two and half, three years.
I know man, well I missed you.
I know, you do.
You've been on a pretty interesting
COVID adventure though.
I just got back from New York city and I think it's the only
time I've been in New York city when you weren't there.
And I so heavily associate you with the city
and you're no longer of New York.
It is really strange place to be.
I mean, I grew up outside of the city,
like my wife, Stephanie grew up outside of the city.
We've lived in New York city for 30 years.
And so, you know that that's been home for three decades.
We like, had a kid raise it a daughter in New York city.
She's 100% city kid.
We built businesses in the city, communities in the city.
Yeah, I had a recording studio for like our podcast
in the city, in our apartment actually.
Right.
Which you have been to many times.
And we hit a point where, you know,
New York city was kind of the tip of the spirit
when it came to the pandemic last year,
you know, in the spring.
It was a terrifying place to be,
absolutely terrifying place to be.
In part because hit us so hard and so deep
and before there was really any understanding of what
this was and had to navigate it in any meaningful way.
And you know, there it's the biggest cluster
of people in the country, in the tightest area.
So it's really hard.
Not exactly where you wanna be.
Right.
When there's an outbreak.
Yeah, and yet, you know,
there's so much devastation that happened there.
There's nobody that I know that either
didn't lose someone directly
or know somebody who's not here anymore.
You know, it, it touched our family.
It touched every friend, I know his family and,
and we hit a point where we were producing a show
that kept us in New York also because, you know,
in person similar to the way that you're sort of like
in proximity enough to LA where, you know,
almost anyone you want to talk to you,
it's going to be moving through the city at some point.
So you can grab them, bring them into the studios.
We had the same thing in New York city.
And I always assumed that that was a
core part of what we were doing.
Like my ability to earn a living and sit down with people.
So, when everything changed and the blink of an eye,
we had to completely disrupt our production process
and move to remote and go through that whole thing.
And then figured out we could actually do it.
Then the question became, okay, so
there's no such thing as disruption, without possibility.
Where's the possibility,
because it has to exist and you may not feel it
or see it readily when, when you're in the midst
of being disrupted, but it exists.
It always does.
So then we start to say, okay,
what is this allowing us to potentially think about doing
that we couldn't even conceive of doing before.
Sure once you untether from the idea
that you have to sit across from another human being,
the possibilities become limitless because you're decoupled
from geographic location all of a sudden.
Yeah, and, and, but I had the same struggle as you,
you know, like we've talked about this over the years.
You know, like, can you actually get the depth
and quality of a conversation virtually
that we're having, you know, like just right here,
like face to face where we can see each other,
we can feel each other.
I can hear the sound of your breath.
I can see the nuance of your eyebrows.
You know, so, and I didn't believe it was possible
to do that virtually.
I thought it was completely impossible,
but then we were left the decision of,
we either shut down our show or we figured out.
So we started just cobbling it together and figuring it out.
And what I learned over time was that
my assumptions were wrong.
You know, we were able to create, so, you know,
we record on a platform that gives us super high quality
audio and at the same time I see somebody,
but we don't record the video.
We don't actually share that
it's purely for conversational reference.
And what I learned was that the safe container
that we created in the studio is replaced by
the safety that somebody experiences
when they're in their own setting.
And that transfers into the conversation it's different.
But it, it worked to create intimacy in a level
that I didn't think was possible.
Yeah, it's so interesting.
I think that I never made it over that hump
and held onto this idea that it's impossible.
And I tried, and I think some of those conversations
were successful, but I was still felt lacking
in the sense that a big motivator for me is because I,
I wanna be in relationship with these people too, right.
And there is something that feels a little bit transactional
because as soon as it's over,
you forget who you were talking to or whatever.
But I would say a couple of things.
I mean, first of all, you, you, you did figure it out.
Like I've listened to your show and, you know,
one of the reasons why I felt like it wasn't gonna work
for me is because that emotional piece is really fundamental
and at the core of what I do.
And it's certainly it's even more so for the way that you
approach your conversations and you did figure it out.
And I think what I wasn't able to fully appreciate is that
part about people being comfortable in their own home.
You know, that allows them to just be
a little bit more relaxed.
I mean, here we are in a studio
there's lights, there's camera.
And like, you're, you know, a seasoned veteran at this.
It's not gonna affect you, but for some people it does.
You know, and you're creating the opposite
of what you're trying to achieve.
So perhaps it would be better if it was in a digital format.
I've heard Marin talk about this too.
'Cause he was very reticent
and he said something in a recent podcast
where he's like learned to really love it.
Yeah, and I think it's similar to the way
I now feel about virtual speaking and keynotes.
You know, and I'm literally,
as I sit here within the last 72 hours, I've,
I've just now done my first in-person keynote
in a hall, in a resort.
And then, you know, 16 hours after that
followed up with a virtual keynote where I was in an Airbnb,
you know, like presenting to a senior leadership team,
spread across an entire country.
And, and to have that comparison and in the beginning
I wanted nothing to do with it.
I didn't want the learning curve, I didn't want that.
I thought there's no way I can make the connection.
I can't get the feedback, I'm so interactive.
And you're really similar to me.
And especially in front of an audience, you're like,
we're constantly scanning to see how things are landing so
that we can adapt, give people what they need in the moment.
And it's so much harder to do, and yet there are,
once you start to learn the tools and the platforms,
there are things that you can do
that you can't do in person.
You can get a level of engagement virtually,
which is surprising that you can't do, you know,
you can use things like breakout groups or chats
or different things where the quiet
or the highly sensitive people in an audience,
the introverts who had never raised a hand and participate
in a conversation or do a partner exercise.
You know, when you actually give them a little bit of safety
behind a screen or a chat,
or being able to raise their hand and just share, you know,
through distance profoundly changes the dynamic.
And, and so that happened also with podcasting for me.
But, and it really blew my mind because
I didn't see it coming.
I literally questioned whether we were going to have to shut
down because I have that similar value set to you.
I'm like, we need to produce at a certain level.
And if I can't do that, I have no interest in doing this.
Right.
You know, like we're like the standards is very high
and, and I was really concerned
that we wouldn't be able to do it.
And it took a while to figure out,
but I feel like we pretty much have figured out.
And sure there's some people where you're right.
If there are kids running in the background
or it's like an environment where they don't feel
completely cloistered and safe,
then you know, it might not work.
We don't air every conversation that we record,
which is sort of like a dirty secret of podcasting.
Yeah, yeah there's only been maybe two in the history
of me doing this.
Two that I can recall maybe a third one
where I didn't air it.
And I'm such a people pleaser
and I have such porous boundaries.
'Cause I think you called me every time,
so what should we do.
Whereas you're, you're, you're ruthless with that, right.
You'll do one, and just be like, this is not,
we're not doing it.
It's not ruthless, 'cause I like you.
If people show up and they give their time,
you know, like I really want to respect that.
I want to be generous and respectful.
And at the same time, my ultimate responsibility
is to our listening community, you know.
And I can't violate that trust or else everything is over.
So if for some reason we feel like they're just something
happened or didn't happen in a way that, you know,
would make somebody tune in and say, okay,
I've just given it an hour, an hour and a half of my life.
And I don't quite think it was worth it.
I don't ever wanna break that trust.
You know, that is the most sacred bond of trust.
I know you feel that way also.
Yeah, I definitely, I definitely do,
but I still struggle with, with the boundaries thing,
you know, a little bit for you.
We've actually, by the way, like we we've like paid
the travel and accommodation fees
that people where we felt really bad.
Oh really, where that's happened.
Like, so we try and do the right thing.
You know, like if somebody's really invested in being here,
I sort of, I live increasingly by the,
the motto of maximum sustainable generosity.
You know, I'm sort of like constantly scanning.
That's the way I want to build the business.
That's the way I want to build friendships.
That's the way I want to exist in the world.
And sometimes I meet that and sometimes I fail, but I try.
Explain that a little bit though,
maximum sustainable generosity.
Yeah so, you know, when I think about in business,
we take business, for example,
'cause it's a fairly straightforward way of looking at it.
How could you launch and grow a business?
How do you market something?
I'm launching a book, how do I actually bring that
to the world, right.
Well, I would love to have a lot of people
become aware of the ideas.
So how do I share that?
Well, I could spend a lot of money to buy attention
and then ask people to essentially like exchange
money for an idea.
And we'll do some of that.
But my brain says, increasingly, what can we create?
That will be generative and generous.
Even if somebody never like buys a thing from me,
what can we offer to the world to individuals,
if I never meet them in my entire life,
that will, in some way, make the moment they're in better.
And maybe they end up actually turning around and saying,
wow, I want to go deeper into this, but maybe they don't.
But I still want to lead with being generous with
things that I create with my time with,
you know, share of mind, share of heart,
share of whatever it is that I can share.
But at the same time now there's the sustainable part
is in the middle of that phrase.
You know, it's not maximum generosity
because that can lead to major boundary issues in burnout.
And I'm somebody who's like, I'm in an HSP,
highly sensitive person.
So I know that socially, I have sort of like boundaries
and I need recovery.
And also I run a business and support a family.
So how do I do it in a way that is emotionally sustainable,
that is cognitively sustainable
and that's financially sustainable, you know.
So I'm constantly running those scripts in my head saying,
how can I give to a point where
everything is sustainable for me,
where I'm not going to hit a point where I'm completely
and utterly burned out on all three planes,
because then I can't do any of it anymore.
Yeah, it takes a certain level of,
of deep self understanding to know where
those lines are though.
I find myself,
with a malleable definition of sustainability
because I I'm like, I get excited about ideas
and I convince myself that I can make it work
or make it fit.
And constantly then end up in burnout situations.
We've talked a lot about this over the years, you know,
and I've gotten better, but I still, you know,
I'm climbing that mountain.
And I'm not like for me, this is an aspirational standard.
It doesn't mean like I wake up every morning
and I hate that standard.
It's just like, I just keep asking myself the question,
like, what would the action or the decision be
that would allow me align as closely
with that standard of maximum sustainable generosity.
Sometimes I rise to it.
Sometimes it completely utterly fail.
And sometimes I like, like you, I,
I kind of forget the sustainability part in the middle
and I end up wrecked.
Yeah.
You know, and then I realized, oh, well, yeah,
that was nice for a hot minute.
And now it's going to take a lot of recovery.
Yeah, I feel a kinship with you in the sense that,
I feel we both kind of lead with the heart,
but you're much more systems oriented than I am.
Like you figured out ways to organize your life
and, in a manner that I still struggle with.
And I think that's an interesting,
you know, way to kind of launch into the new book
and everything that we're going to talk about today.
This idea of, of combining, you know, understanding that,
that, that is sort of a super power for you,
but also simultaneously understanding that the best way to
leverage that is by using some rationality
and logic to organize your life in a manner that,
that does make it sustainable for you to give in that way.
Yeah, I mean, the you're right.
You and I both lead with the heart a lot.
And I think the systems and the,
like the scaffolding for me is a survival mechanism.
It doesn't come naturally to me.
I don't enjoy doing it, I don't enjoy creating it.
And I don't enjoy following systems, process and rules.
I am much more rebellious, you know, like I'm a maker,
which means I'm a lateral thinker.
Like I opened my eyes in the morning and I'm thinking
outside of whatever box I constructed
when I close my eyes and night before.
That's not by will, it's just the way that my brain works,
the way that my life has been structured.
But at the same time, I like to be generative.
I like to have meaningful output come from
whatever's going on, you know,
like from all of those thoughts.
And I've come to realize that if I don't have structure
around it in some meaningful way,
that I'm just spinning ideas, you know, and it's fun,
but nothing ever happens.
Yeah, but you're also very good, you know, on that,
that idea of creating a foundation or a scaffold
to not just organize your life, but create
an idea that's scalable
and applicable to other people's lives.
Which is really, you know, the basis of all the work
that you do.
Yeah, you know, it's interesting, you know,
that before we went entirely into podcasting,
we were producing a video series
and we were filming everything.
And our producer has reminded me many times
that the single most referenced person by me
in the history of our show is Milton Glaser.
Who I had the opportunity to sit down with.
He passed about two years ago.
And Milton, as you know, was maybe one of the most iconic
designers who, who has lived in the last 100 years.
And I sat down with him in his studio.
People won't know the name if you're not in design,
but they know his work.
Like he, he created the I heart NY logo
on the back of a napkin in a cab in the 70s,
in New York and gave it to the city for like no money,
simply because he had a love affair with the city
that he grew up in and lived in,
and he wanted to do something to help it come back
with this massive devastating,
like near bankruptcy situation.
He was a co-founder of New York magazine.
He's created all these iconic things like the famous,
like Bob Dylan rainbow hair poster.
Like everybody knows his work, but if you're not in design.
He did the IBM logo too?
I don't know if he did that one.
But a bunch of logos that we all know well.
You know, he taught for like 40 years at Cooper Union.
So he's influenced thousands of designers then gone out
and effectively created the world that we live in.
And sitting down with him in conversation, which was,
you know, we wrapped that conversation.
And the whole team was just like, does it have to end?
Because it was this magical moment.
But he said something to me,
a few minutes of that conversation.
He said, I've known what I wanted to do
since I was five or six years old.
So I didn't know, I would want to be a designer.
But what I knew then was that I learned to make things.
And then he said, you're like me.
I think he said, my dad, you know, told me, you know,
like if you can make things in some way
are like meaningful to other people.
Like that's even better because maybe that becomes a career.
So in my mind, what I heard was
I make things that move people.
And I said, I literally was vibrating
because every cell in my body was just like
me too, me too, me too.
And I couldn't get it out of my mind.
And it's funny, actually,
we're about to roll out a whole new personal website for me.
And the top line now says, I make things that move people.
And I can't have that last part of it
unless I build the structure around it, you know.
I can make all sorts of stuff,
but to have it be able to scale on a level
where it's meaningful, not just to me, but to other people
and actually make a difference in their lives,
that takes more.
I mean, like we're in a studio now,
like we've been friends for a long time.
Five years ago, you didn't have this structure.
No.
You know, you have a level of structure around you
and a team around you that is allowing you
to reach exponentially more people and go deeper
into people's lives and spend like stunning
to witness what you've created.
So you may not recognize that in yourself,
but it is 100% there.
Yeah, I mean, I'm able to appreciate it,
I think on some level, but you know, on this idea of,
of us going way back, I mean, I would be remiss.
You've been on the podcast before,
but it's been a very long time.
I would be remiss in not acknowledging
the extraordinary impact that you've had on me
over the years throughout our friendship,
but even predating our friendship.
I mean, you were impacting me in ways.
You have no idea about back,
I don't know, 2000s, early 2000s.
Like back to the early days of career Renegade
and all the work that you were doing around,
you know, helping writers.
I mean, I see you, this will,
we'll get into this more.
In-depth in the, in the sparketype discussion,
but I've always seen you as, as sort of a mentor
from afar and now up close.
But also as a teacher and somebody who always
this question that your book kind of opens up with,
which is what should I do with my life.
There are so many people who feel adrift or lost
or struggling with this idea of how to, you know,
pursue a life of, of meaning and fulfillment, et cetera.
That's always been at the core of your work.
And you were a very early internet adopter
and understanding the powerful tools that
the internet allowed you to, to leverage,
to, to reach people.
And I, I remember conversations with friends way,
like I remember the first time my buddy Mark Ant said,
do you know this guy, Jonathan Fields,
you should check out his website.
He's got all this stuff, it's about unlocking creativity.
And I went down this rabbit hole of
all this stuff that you were doing way back then.
And it's been this constant
process or evolution of reinvention, refinement,
figuring out what your voice is and how to impact people
in the most meaningful way that, that you possibly could.
And we didn't meet until
I was a guest on Good Life project back in.
When we were filming.
2012, and you were the first guy
who was doing podcasting in video format
at a very high level.
Like you had super pro you know, cameras and team
and editing and all of that and created this very polished
product way ahead of the curve.
And I've often thought like, why didn't he keep doing that?
Like he liked, Yeah, I know, you know.
To know like you've dummy.
I mean, I think the video that we did together
back then still gets views.
Oh, yeah, for sure.
Yeah, I mean it's,
it's been an interesting evolution.
Like you said, I was, I was a brick and mortar entrepreneur,
like in the world of yoga and wellbeing
and fitness in New York city.
You know, you know, the story I,
I signed the lease for a floor in a building
in New York city in hell's kitchen, New York city,
a secure lease, married with a three month old baby
to open a yoga studio the day before 911
Right.
You know, and I was all in and brick and mortar
and building community.
But I really got the bug to write and to share,
to build more around just ideas, sharing ideas at scale.
And that's actually what led me to the internet.
And it was, it was actually, it was Tim Ferris
who was the gateway drug for me.
And because I had seen what he did to launch
the very first book for our workweek.
And I was like, huh, here's a guy
who actually completely tapped that world
to do something pretty astonishing with a physical object.
Like eBooks were not a thing
when he first launched that book.
And actually reached out to him.
And I was like, can you talk to me a little bit?
And he be like, this was before Tim
has really exploded into the landscape and the level it is.
And we had a conversation and I realized really quickly,
I need to sort of like start exploring this digital space
in the media space, 'cause I knew nothing about it.
And that was sort of like my entree into it.
And, and then into the world, the books,
and then selling the, you know,
the yoga center in New York city.
But yeah, that video series,
which has how good life project started,
it was 100% video for the first two years or so.
And similarly to what we talked about before,
I'm at a point in my life where if I say yes
to something I want to, I, I want to be in a space
where I'm perpetually raising my own bar
and hopefully raising the bar for the space.
And I said, let's show up and do this.
And people thought I was nuts, including me, and.
But it was like 2010?
2012.
12.
Yeah, and then we pulled out of video
because I fell in love with audio and,
and it wasn't podcast.
It made me fall in love with the audio actually
it was, it was radio.
Because as part of launching that first book
that you mentioned just 2009,
I was on a whole bunch of radio
and I would go into the studio and I put the headphones on
and we're close Mike like this.
And, and then a friend of mine had a show
and it became like a regular guest on our show.
And I was like, this is awesome.
I just, there was something about it.
And then Seth Goden introduced me to one of the founders
of one of the big public radio franchises studio, 360.
Who was a docent at one of the big museums in New York.
And we walked around Monday and I was telling her
kind of falling in love with radio
and especially public radio.
Like, you know, like I think I might want to get into it
and not do the video thing.
And she's kind of like, well, why, why what's your reason?
And I said, well, you're like massive reach.
And I just there's something about it that I love.
Video for reach.
Right, right, she kinda looks at me like,
and I knew it.
I had just like, like I had broken something
in the conversation and I'm like, what am I missing?
She's like, she's like, yeah, yeah, reach.
But she's like the power of audio is it is
the single most intimate medium of everything on the planet.
And the light bulb went on for me.
And as an introvert, as somebody who's quiet
or somebody who has zero need to actually be on screen
or be visually recognizable.
I'm, I'm just as happy sort of like being
the wizard behind the curtain.
It all started to click.
And so my early aspirations were really more, more radio,
but, and at that point, you know,
this because you already in really early also,
everyone was thinking podcast is dying on the vine.
It literally it's, it's the last gasp.
And then Apple splits out the podcast app
and installs it native on every device.
And a couple of months later serial hits
and the universe changes.
It was a huge inflection point of elevated content meets
accessibility, like seamless accessibility.
It wasn't just the app.
It was that you didn't necessarily have to download these
things either like bandwidth expanded enough
so that you could stream them.
And it just became easier, and then cars started
installing that in their dashboards.
And suddenly, I mean, still to this day,
it's like every time I get in an Uber, you know there's the
radio's playing, I go, have you ever listened to a podcast?
And then 99% of the time, they're like, no, I don't do that.
You know, there's still a ways to go, but it,
it it's crazy how much it's grown.
And I would have never thought that
because when we started this,
it was a weird hobbyist thing to do.
It was not a cool thing.
I mean, when you started this, I mean obviously
it was just, it was, it was audio only,
but you weren't alive then, right.
Yeah.
Right, so, I mean.
2012.
Right, so it was like the same time that I started video.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It's amazing.
Well, you must think at times,
like what if I'd kept up the video
because you could always split out the audio
or you could have, the longer you could do,
like beyond being model where you have a longer version
and audio or whatever.
And we actually did that for about a year.
We just ran the audio on the YouTube channel
because we had a bunch of subscribers there.
And, and I'm actually, we're now literally
as we had this conversation sitting down with my team
and we're exploring different video formats,
what I'm trying to figure out actually
is how can we reanimate the video side of what we're doing?
Because we know that YouTube is the second
or third largest podcast platform.
So there's a huge audience there that doesn't wanna leave
like that platform to actually consume.
And for long form conversations like this,
you know, this is beautifully produced.
You're doing an astonishing job.
And yet I also know, and you know,
that a lot of people are actually just letting
this run in the background.
Sure.
You know, so what I'm trying to figure out is
between knowing that not having a strong affinity
and also not feeling called to sort of like
spend a lot of time visually in front of people,
but I really want the ideas and the conversations
and whatever spotlight I have to share
on other people and their ideas
and their stories and insights I want to be able to do that
at the biggest scale possible.
How do we step back into video in a way that is,
it goes back to what we're talking about.
Again, maximum sustainable generosity.
How do we increase the generosity and the spread
of the ideas and the insights and the individuals
in a way that I that's sustainable for me at the same time?
Well, a couple observations on that.
First of all, YouTube is also a massive search engine
and they figured out discoverability
in a way that podcasting still struggles with.
So a certain video will get recommended
to people who are not subscribers of you.
And it's able to travel across the internet
in a way that a podcast episode is not able to.
So I think that makes it powerful as well.
And just the visual association creates
a deeper emotional connection to the host
or the guest or what have you.
But I think the important point that I want to make is that,
and this is something I I've always appreciated about you
is that you're never one to say, oh, everybody's doing this
like I should do that too.
You're always looking for the white space.
Like, what are people not doing?
Like when everybody's zigging your zagging, okay.
We're we wanna get back into video, but like, what is the,
you know, what are people not seeing?
What's a new way to imagine how we could
make a presence on this platform, but do it in a unique way
that is commeasured with your sensibility.
Yeah, I don't like doing what everyone else.
No, no, no it's good, you know.
Zag oriented, you know.
And I look at like, I look at what we're creating here
and it blows my mind.
I'm in awe of this, of what you've built
and you know, what you offer to your community.
And at simultaneously, my mind is like,
I'm so glad something visual, but yeah,
like the Android is like, God bless them.
Put a serious ranch in your ability to be nomadic.
Right.
The way that you are right now.
Right, I mean,
and that's the only we haven't talked about.
But, but at the same time, I'm kind of like,
what is nobody else doing right now?
Like if I'm going to step back into video,
which we are going to, what's nobody else doing right now?
Because again, if I wanna step into it,
I wanna create a different bar.
I wanna figure out how to do something that is really
strongly differentiated in the space,
but not just to be different,
but in a way that I feel like in some way changes the way
that the conversation, the insights of stories are received.
And I haven't quite figured that out yet,
but we're running a lot of experiments
behind the stage right now to do it.
Yeah, I'm confident that you will.
And you, it's funny that you said,
you ended that with this experience, you're,
you're always saying, well, we're, we're,
we're split testing this.
And I'm like, who's we?
Like who are all these people
that are running all these crazy tests?
And you're getting all these data sets.
This is the scientist in you, this, this, you know,
secondary sparketype that you have.
Which is probably a good way to get into
talking about the new book and this idea of, you know,
what we should do with our lives.
Talk me through the Genesis of this idea
because you've been working on this for a very long time.
Probably a couple decades.
When we were at Mel's house,
you were talking about this book.
I think you had even written
major portions of this at that time.
Yeah, we, we were, the body of work
had really started to form, but,
but the true Genesis is probably two to three decades old.
You know, this is, you brought up the question earlier,
which is the center of really my professional life
for my entire adult life.
It's just, which is, you know, that question,
what should I do with my life?
And what I found is that, whether I'm writing books,
whether I was teaching yoga for years
and meditation, whether I was no matter where I was,
that is sort of the singular question
that people kept asking me.
I don't know why, but it's the thing that kept coming up
over and over and over again.
What I realized over time
is when they're asking me in particular,
especially after I was sort of in the world that business
and had built a number of small businesses
and they were asking me more particularly,
how do I find and do work that makes me come alive?
And I realized that we had, we there's the we again, right.
I think I sometimes hide behind that to be honest with you.
How many people are involved in this mysterious we?
Just a couple thousand.
(Rich laughing)
We have a small team, but you know,
the, the original idea really is, you know, me saying, okay,
I've worked with a lot of founders and a lot of
entrepreneurs in the world of business to,
to deconstruct how they look at the businesses
that they're thinking about building
so that it's not just about quote, product market fit.
Can I actually fill a need from the market
and build a business that's successful on the outside
because it's sustaining itself financially,
but it's also about what I would call product and maker fit.
Can I build something that is also fiercely aligned
with the essential nature of the way
that I need to contribute to the world,
which almost nobody explorers.
And I ended up focusing really heavy on that.
I actually think it's much more complex
than product market fit.
And then I started to realize that I've been focused so much
on the question, the context of founders and entrepreneurs,
but there are so many ideas spinning in my head
and questions around just work in general,
whether it's your career, whether it's your devotion,
whether it's the thing that you love to do on the side,
whether it's a role that you play.
You know, you know, being a parent is work.
Like being a caretaker is work.
You know, whether you get paid for it or not
like the thing where you open your eyes
and you invest a huge amount of effort in it,
like how do we do that in a way that
gives us the feeling that we wanna have.
And, and when I use the phrase come alive,
like how do you do work that comes alive?
I deconstruct that because this was a big part
of what I had to figure out.
Like, what do I actually mean by that?
Like, I feel a lot awesome.
But how do I actually understand what that is
in a way where I can,
I can make it fairly systematic and replicable
across any number of domains that I step into.
So for me, what, when I use that phrase,
it deconstructs to five things, one is meaningfulness.
It has to be meaningful to me and hopefully to other people,
it has to matter.
I have to feel like the thing that I'm working on
matters and there's a sense of meaning associated with it.
It also, to me includes the experience of flow.
So that, that blissed out state,
that where you become completely absorbed in the thing,
there's a non differentiation between you
and the task that the goal, whatever it is,
you get lost time Fuchs, you know,
there's a ton of research on,
on all of these individual things
and how they affect us in a profound way.
So I'm interested in these well-researched domains,
but bringing them all together into one state
express potential.
So I feel like, you know,
all of me is being brought forward,
not just like pieces of it.
I don't just show up and segment who I am,
but the fullness of who I am, what I care about
and the impulse that I have to get out
is being brought to bear.
We also look at excitement and enthusiasm.
Which, you know, the corporate world kind
of phrases as engagement these days.
And the final one is purpose in life,
a broader sense of purpose in life.
So we often talk about purpose in the context of a
particular project or domain.
Like I wake up in the morning, I have a sense of purpose
because I'm working to accomplish this particular thing.
Which is really good and really important.
But more broadly, and there's really powerful research
in the field of positive psychology and social science
on what the phrase, purpose in life.
If you have a sense of purpose in life,
there are all sorts of follow on benefits
that flow from that in terms of health,
wellbeing, cognitive function, mental health.
And each one of these are really well-researched.
And I said to me, these are the five components
that come together.
So when I use the phrase as a shorthand, come alive.
Now and do work, how do I find to do work
that makes you come alive?
That's what I'm talking about.
Work that gives me those things.
Yeah, that's a very mindful and intentional way
of approaching what tends to be kind of
these ephemeral concepts of, of living a passionate life
or pursuing a life of meaning.
And I think you're exactly right.
Like what does that actually mean?
I mean, when we talk about the terms that,
that capture the life we aspire to lead,
we tend to talk about passion and purpose and meaning
and fulfillment and authenticity
and self-actualization and, and impact.
And it's very confusing because it's so abstract,
it's really hard to grasp what any of that means,
let alone how you would drill down
and translate that into anything actionable.
It's, it's almost impossible to achieve that
because those words are about they're about emotion, right.
And there are about results,
but they tell us very little about how to achieve them.
Yeah, and that there are about feelings,
which are subjective.
Yeah.
You know, so if you look at the research
in each of these domains, it's interesting
because there's a lot of it.
And, and it may, when you look at the numbers,
you're like, oh, there's a ton of research,
clear, like, you know, clear outcomes and, you know.
But when you really drill down into the research,
you're like, there's also a lot of best guessing.
Yeah, so if you look at the research on happiness,
which I happen to like have an issue with a lot of happiness
based and sort of like aspirations.
But when you look at the resource at where
there's all the like granular statistics about like do this,
and you're happier by 5% and this and that,
we ask yourself, how are they measuring happiness?
And then you look at like the measures
and there'll be things like.
And how are they defining happiness.
Did you laugh in the last 24 hours?
Right, so how they define it is completely subjective
and different across all the different studies.
So you'll have somebody say,
you know, use meaningfulness instead of happiness.
It's, it's, there's a lot of roughness
and all of the research around all of these things.
But I keep going for me, like the thing that the,
of all the things that we've talked about,
the biggest pole for me is an exploration of meaning.
You know, that, to me, happiness is the snapshot,
meaning is the movie.
You know, happiness is a state that we pass through.
It's like, when you're training for an event, right.
You can't be in peak fitness on a perpetual basis,
you'll destroy yourself.
It's, it's just impossible.
Sure, and it's not exactly in a, in an overall sense,
it's a pursuit that makes me happy,
but it's not an experience of happiness, right.
Yeah.
It's a meaningful experience.
Right, so there's like, we conflate these words, you know.
I think because there's so much confusion around that.
And so little common defining of those terms,
it leaves, and you talk about this in the book.
Like it leaves people confused and frustrated and paralyzed.
And I think, you know, experiencing
guilt or shame because they haven't figured it out.
I mean, here we are emerging out of this COVID area.
Everybody is thinking more deeply about their relationship
to their profession and to work
in ways that we didn't before.
And because our culture over indexes on some of those terms,
I think it leaves most people feeling less than.
100%.
Because they don't have it figured out
or so-and-so on Instagram is living their life of passion
or is on a Caribbean beach or something like that.
And you're in your cubicle wandering what is,
what it is exactly that gives your life meaning and purpose.
Yeah, I mean, I call it happiness shame.
You know, there there's a certain expectation there there's,
there's a certain line of thought
that says the ultimate aspiration is to be happy.
So we should aspire to just live a happy life.
And if you ask you the average parent,
what do you want for your kid?
They're going to say like on that to be happy.
But the reality is if, if you know that a,
it's not a persistent state, it's,
it's a moment that we pass through, like here and there,
and which is awesome.
But to expect to live there, to dwell in that state
is setting yourself up for a futility and failure.
And for many, a sense of shame
because you haven't lived up to the expectation
that you've been told is possible, it's not.
You know, so there's research that actually shows
the direct pursuit of happiness leaves you less happy.
You know, you do other things.
That are meaningful, that are relational, that, you know,
and a side benefit is it will increase
our late the net happiness.
But the other part of that equation
that's not often talked about is that
in the context of happiness, in particular,
similar to sort of like metabolism
and other physiological markers,
it's pretty commonly accepted at this point,
that happiness is in part,
at least based on genetic set point.
I seen data that says anywhere between 40 and 60%
of your sort of like average set point for happiness
is based on genetics, right.
So if you happen to be wired, to just be more
on the melancholy side and then the world around you
is telling you that to be okay, you actually need to
be like, yay, all day long.
You know, that you need to be like exist at a 75% happy,
but you're wired, and you're kind of okay,
being like, you know, just who you are.
But you're being told that that means you're broken.
Well, then you feel even more broken
rather than just saying, you know, actually
I'm okay with myself.
So there's, there's, I'm fascinated by the world
of happiness and how you look at the research,
and then you look at how that's been translated into
common perception and ethics and prescriptions
and how there's a lot that's gone missing in the middle.
And, and ultimately, sure, I want to be happy.
I want my kid to be happy, I want my friends to be,
I want you to be happy, right.
But more than that, I want you to feel like you matter,
I want you to feel like what you're doing is meaningful.
I want you to feel like you're surrounded by relationships
that nourish you at the end of the day.
And you're making a difference.
I want you to feel like there's something inside of you
that makes you open your eyes in the morning.
And if you exert effort in alignment with it,
you just feel good.
Even that you have no understanding of why.
And you figured that out.
And then you figured out a way to actually contribute
to the world that lets you do that.
That's what matters to me.
So how do you take that ambition
and create a roadmap or a structure
that will allow people to,
you know, discover that within themselves,
that can be more expressed so they can actualize
that in their lives.
Yeah, well, first I run from it
because I don't want to be the person who has
to try and grapple with.
That's a very, ambitious, yeah.
Cause I got other stuff to do.
I wanna paint, I want to build other things,
I wanna write and create.
The scientist comes out, right.
This is a big problem.
This is a very macro social problem.
You know, it's what economists would call a wicked problem
and it's unique to each person.
And so I started to look at a lot of, you know,
when I think about how do we actually,
how do we find, how do we understand?
What is, what is the work that,
that gives us this feeling of coming alive?
Like how do we invest ourselves in that invest effort
in a way that gives us that feeling?
First, I'm looking at the signs.
Cause I'm like, if it's out there,
I don't want to recreate it.
I just want us to help point people to it.
And like, there's a lot of science,
but a lot of is not all that accessible.
And it's, it's very siloed.
And then I look at what other paths I look at philosophy.
I look at psychology, I look at spirituality
and the each had their prescribed paths
and their, their edicts and their offerings.
And they're, they're great.
There's a lot of value in each one of them.
And if you buy into the sort of like the systems that,
you know, that would allow you to learn these things,
that's great, you know, but spirituality,
there's a lot of great, great work that you can do
and pass and traditions.
And we know a lot of people in that space
who are phenomenal teachers, and at the same time,
they also often buy, require you to buy into a larger
scheme of dogma, that a lot of people will tap out on.
So they'll run from the tools simply because
they don't want to buy into the bigger ecosystem.
So my mind started to say, all right, how do I tap that?
How do I do my own original thinking and create something?
So the maker may as like,
how do I make something that moves people?
And the scientist says, we need to figure out
a complex problem here.
How do we create something, an idea, a set of tools
that are profoundly accessible and useful for anybody,
no matter what you believe in,
or don't believe in no matter where you come from,
what your political philosophical, spiritual bent is.
You know, you can show up, interact with these ideas
and tools and be like, oh, that helped.
That matters to me, and that was a starting point for me.
I actually didn't really want to dive into this
because I knew it was going to be a
years, years, long process.
But I also knew that it was the evolution
of where my mind has been focusing for decades now.
So for many years, you steep yourself in the science,
the social psychology, all of the research.
And that leads you to essentially a series of questions
that you've refined over time.
And in answering these questions, each individual,
it begins to paint a picture of
what you call a person's sparketype.
So walk me through that.
And these 10 sparketype that you've come up with,
because there is an essential realism to this.
I know that your original manuscript for this book
was like 10 times longer than the book.
By the way, I didn't say it, but like the book is fantastic
and it's, it's beautifully rendered,
but I think it's, its power is in its simplicity.
Like it's a book that you can pick up and you can really,
you know, not just learn immediately,
but take these tools and apply them to your life
because it's relatable.
And there is, there is, there is a,
and Milton would be very proud in how these ideas have been
distilled down in a way that makes them very practical.
Yeah, well, when I said yes to all of this work,
part of what I want to say yes to was,
I wanted to create a way for people to feel seen.
First by themselves and then to help explain
themselves to others and have others see themselves
for who they really are.
Because we are profoundly unseen in this world.
And when that happens, that the level of revelation
and connection externally that alone,
even if I never like said, gave any prescriptive
information on top of that is transformative.
But in the context of creating actual tools in the book
and these 10 types that you mentioned,
I called them sparketypes,
because it it's a fun shorthand for archetypes
for work that sparked you or makes you come alive.
You know, and we're using those five elements
to really focus in on that.
I kind of hate the fact that I've identified 10 of them
because it feels way too slick.
It's like, it's, I'm a marketer
and this feels a way to market it for me.
I'm like, couldn't it have been nine or 14
or something like that.
But, you know, you start out with,
basically I start with it's really big lens and say, okay,
so what is the fundamental impulse that people have
for effort that gives them this feeling?
Is it really as unique
and distinct as 7.5 billion distinct impulses?
Could that really be true?
Are we all those delicate flowers who have to be completely
unique from everyone else?
And on the surface, for sure it can express itself
in billions of different ways.
But if you keep drilling down and saying, well,
what's underneath that, what's underneath that.
How do we reconstruct deconstruct this role,
this job, this devotion, what are the fundamental impulses
for effort underneath it?
It distills astonishingly quickly down to these 10
fundamental impulses ways that you exert yourself,
ways that you work.
And once I sort of like landed on those,
I started to ask myself this question, okay,
so we've got these 10 universal impulses.
Are there a set of also fairly mappable tendencies,
preferences and behaviors that are associated
with each of these?
Like, so for me, like I'm, I'm my, my sparketype.
My impulse is I'm a maker, I make ideas manifest.
I'd wake up in the morning, and my fundamental impulse
for contribution for work is to make ideas manifest.
Now that is the impulse for effort,
but built around that, it's this really interesting
shared set of preferences and behaviors
and tendencies that make you really similar
to millions of other people.
And that's what forms the archetype
or the sparketype around these things.
So it's a blend of the impulse.
And then the way that the impulse shows up
and relates to the world around it,
and those are those 10 things.
So the 10 things are maker, which you just mentioned,
making ideas manifest.
We have the Maven, which is the person who,
who lives to learn.
And I loved how you use Neil, our friend, Neil Pasricha as,
as this sort of leading example in that chapter.
The most curious person maybe I have ever met
on the planet.
Relentlessly, relentlessly curious.
Yeah, he's like if you meet him,
there's not a stranger that he's ever met in his life
where you don't, you know,
that stranger doesn't walk away 20 minutes later.
And without Neil knowing everything about that.
(Rich laughs)
I know, I know.
It's amazing.
And he does it, that's his disposition.
You realize, right.
Like this is just how this guy is wired.
Right.
And that's the point.
Right, really quickly, this isn't a facade.
It's not an effort thing where he's sort of like, quote,
networking and going down the list of questions
he has to ask, he's just like, oh my God,
another human being I can learn about them and their life
and the way they think and move through the world.
How incredible is that, that I just get to learn.
I know the earnestness of it all, right.
Yeah.
The scientist, which is your secondary sparketype.
And that's all about figuring things out.
That's the burning question, quandary puzzle person,
you know, and if you're not a scientist,
what we've learned is scientists tend to really
run from that work, but scientists can't get enough of it.
And in fact, one of the risks is that they lose themselves
in it, especially if it's a big thorny problem.
The, another sort of ripple in this whole thing is this
idea of having your primary sparketype
and then your secondary.
So your primary is maker, your secondary is scientist.
Yeah, so, so there is certainly three elements
of what I would call your profile.
There's the primary, which is the strongest impulse.
There's the shadow or secondary.
And you can look at that as sort of like the runner up,
or but there tends to be very often a much more
nuanced relationship, which is you do the work
of your shadow in order to be able
to do the work of your primary better.
So for me, I'm a maker, scientists.
Maker primary, scientist shadow.
I wake up in the morning and I'm like, what can I make?
It's 100% generative as much as I can be.
But in the context of being of, of creation,
you hit problems.
You hit issues that need like, you know,
like to sort of like, okay,
let me go into the figured out mindset.
I'm not actually in the process of being
super generative at that point,
but I'm figuring out things that need to be figured out.
And as soon as I'm done with that, I'm back into generation.
There's one other piece of it, which we added in actually,
there's been an evolution of the work
that I call the anti-spam archetype.
And that is the work that most people experiences
as the most emptying the heaviest lift
and requiring the most recovery from.
You, didn't mention your anti.
Well, I'm not completely done with the book yet,
but I don't think that you mentioned
what your anti-immigrant.
I might not have in the book.
Like you said, I wrote a bazillion pages and cuts so much.
I'm trying to remember if that guy.
So what is your anti?
To my anti sparketype is essentialist.
Which, and the fundamental work of the essentialist
is creating order from chaos.
It's distilling ideas and concepts and training them into
systems and processes to create clarity
and utility for others.
I have become good at that because you like,
it's something that's a mandatory
part of almost anything you do if you're building something.
So, you know, in the early days of a business,
I don't have other people that I can pay to do that.
So I've had, had to learn the skill of getting good at it,
but just because I've become competent in it
doesn't mean that it's the type of work that nurses me.
Yeah, it's the reluctant thing that you have to do.
The idea of the maker scientists is pretty interesting.
And the more I thought about that and how it fits
with you and what I know about you,
I realized, and tell me if you agree with this,
that when I think about some of the best
non-fiction writers out there, Malcolm Gladwell,
David Epstein, James Cleer, Tim Ferris,
Neil Strauss, like, they all seem to me
like maker scientists.
There are people that make things,
but the books that they write
are so steeped in answering questions.
And so research-based that
the thing that they make couldn't be as good as it is
without all of that work that goes into
solving those problems as the quote unquote scientist.
So you would assume that from the outside in,
but what I have learned working with these ideas
and tools for years now
is that you can't assume anything
from the outside looking in.
Because like any one of those people
could have been a maven.
And they just said, I want to learn everything
that I can possibly learn about this one particular topic.
And I wanna spend years doing it and,
and learn at a level of nuance that is so much more profound
than anything I've ever seen before,
but I can't get paid just to do that.
So I'm gonna have a publisher write me a cheque that will
essentially fund my PhD for the next five years to learn.
And my promise to them is I'm gonna
share what I've learned in a compelled.
I'll write the book, but that's not the driver.
The driver is the learning in and of itself.
I know, I know somebody who's literally
sold millions of books and who told me very early
in my book career, she said,
I find a topic that I just want to know everything about.
And then I find a publisher who paid me to learn it.
That's so fascinating.
You never know from the outside.
That's so not how I think about things.
Right, and you never like from the outside looking in
what I've learned is sometimes you can kind of like dial in
the, the impulse, you know, you know,
but for the most part, until you sit down
and talk with somebody or until they sort
of like gone through the work
or like completed an assessment, you really,
you don't necessarily know because what shows up on the
surface is not necessarily what the deeper impulse.
Yeah, you have to mind the motivation behind it, right.
Yeah.
So Maven, we mentioned scientist essentialist
we talked about the person who is motivated
to create order from chaos.
Then there's the performer, the person who turns
moments into magic, as you say.
Yeah, that's all about
animating and enlivening interaction experience, or moment.
One of the least prevalent of all the types.
The Sage.
The Sage is all about elimination.
It's about instilling insight.
A lot of people would call that person a t-shirt,
but they show up in literally every domain,
even when they don't think that that's the role
that they're playing, which is kind of fascinating.
These are the people that the motivation behind
their learning is so that they can share it.
Yeah, so they tend to learn in a very different way
than the average person learns
because they're not just learning because
they're interested or curious about it.
They're not learning
because they're trying to solve a problem.
They're learning because they know that the next move is
going to be to turn around and share this
in a way where other people get it.
And they have to actually understand it
in a very different way.
So I remember, you know,
like we both have a very past life in the law.
Right.
You know, when I was in law school,
very fortunate to be on this, you know, on law review,
there was just this journal.
And the editor in chief once told me, you know,
she was teaching classes like tagging in for professors
when she was still in school.
I was like, how are you doing that?
And she said, like, she, I remember her telling me that.
She said, I learn everything, everything that I learned,
I won't stop studying and learning
until I feel like I know enough to turn around
and teach it tomorrow.
So, so the Sage tends to learn differently
from everybody else because they have a different purpose
and knowledge acquisition.
Yeah, that's so foreign to me.
Me too.
It's not my.
It's so weird when you think about it
and we'll go through the rest of them.
But this idea that, that I think what we do
innately is project, you know, this blueprint
of how we see on the world,
on everybody else that we interact with, right.
Because I'm a, I'm a primary X and a secondary Y,
of course, that's how everybody else processes information
and learns and thinks about, you know,
what they do in the world.
And that just leads to, you know,
all kinds of problems and confusion and resentments,
especially in the workplace.
You're like, why can't you just do the thing,
like the way that I do it.
Yeah, I mean, it's the classic.
If you have a hammer, the world is a nail problem.
Right.
You know, and you absolutely see that
in the work around the Sprocket types.
You know, if, if you wake up in the morning
and you have this somewhat innate impulse
to just work in a particular way,
simply because of the way it makes you feel,
it makes you feel good alive.
It's hard to conceive that that's unique to you.
You just kind of figure that everybody else
is wired that way too.
And then when they don't do it and they,
they're not as excited and they don't invest themselves
as much in it, it bothers you.
And you may view them through the lens of being, oh,
you're lazy, or you're not committed or you're slacking off,
or you don't understand how important this is.
It's like, no, it's not there jam.
Yeah.
And that's okay.
It comes up in parenting too.
100%.
Yeah, this must've been, you know, you,
as you being a parent, it must be illuminating
and how you communicate with your daughter.
It is, you know, because I think
she's actually wired really similarly to me,
in a lot of ways, you know, like not just this.
So going really deep in to understand, not just the impulse,
but also these, the preferences, tendencies and behaviors
tend to wrap around it.
And the relational styles that get built around it,
it really helped me understand myself better.
But I think it also helped me understand how to nourish that
and how to understand her a little bit better.
I don't think you can eat necessarily
do that with every kid.
You know, there's a level of self-awareness
and a depth and quality of experiences
that would allow these things
to reveal themselves over time.
And I think generally they tend to reveal themselves
why I believe they're established very early in life.
They tend to reveal themselves gradually over time
and some reveal themselves much earlier than others.
So the maker, for example,
what we've seen is that tends to show up really early.
Like you can identify that impulse really early,
and there's a reason for it.
It's not because it naturally just emerges.
It's because culturally it's rewarded
from the earliest days, you know, like creativity, painting,
making dire (murmurs) in school.
Every class you go to, like part of the activities
are let's make something, right.
So the person who is innately drawn to that and flourishes,
and then starts to Excel at it and wants to do more
and more of it, because it just makes them feel amazing.
That's offered nonstop from the earliest age
and it's rewarded on a regular basis.
So that tends to reveal itself and be celebrated.
Whereas other impulses can be the exact opposite.
So one of them we've talked about is the performer.
With that there's an interesting thing
that we've seen happen over and over.
Which is that if you're really young, you know,
a lot of parents will sort of like push that impulse
into performing arts because there there's no sort
of like ready, oh, like I can figure out all these
like 20 different ways that this impulse
can actually express itself.
The easiest way is to really performing arts.
Great as a kid, then the kid becomes a teen
and still loves doing all these things.
And the parents start to think.
I get worried.
Yeah, they're getting really worried.
Kids are like, my kid is gonna be living
with eight roommates for the rest of their lives.
And like never be,
and which like, look, we get it, we're both parents.
Like you want your kid to be able to beat, you know,
to feel secure and they can sustain themselves in the world.
But at the same time, what I've seen happen is that
the message gets handed down that says,
not only this isn't really inappropriate
thing to devote yourself to,
but it's not actually a valid impulse
and that is devastating.
And it leads to a lot of stifling and a lot of shame
when you step away from it or you stifle it fiercely
and it never goes away,
but you're told that it's not valid and you can't do it.
Yeah, it's really interesting.
You tell the story of being backstage at Mel's TV show
and the interaction that you have with this woman
who you're gonna go on stage and kind of
perform this of type excavation and how
introverted and kind of withdrawn she was backstage,
the surprise being that she actually tested as
a performer and then kind of mining, you know,
what led her to be in that repressed state.
And it goes back to, you know,
those impulses not being well-received
and the repression that follows.
And I think secondary to that is this idea that,
you know, on the piece of like, oh,
the performer is the person who's gonna, you know,
pursue a career in Broadway or become a singer.
It's not necessarily that it's much broader than that.
These tendencies can be beneficial or leveraged
in whatever job that you find yourself.
Yeah, they're completely dissociated from jobs, titles,
roles, industries, organizations.
They, they pretty much every single one of them
can be expressed in nearly any of those places.
You know, the performer, for example, you know,
you can find that person in a boardroom,
you can find that person in a sales conversation,
you can find that person behind a bar,
you can find that person as a parent,
who's just creating this magical moment with their kids.
You know, you can find that person as a,
as a teacher in sixth grade.
You know, it really, that was one of the big awakenings
for me is that when most people sort of like go on this hunt
for what should I do with my life,
they start at the level of job.
What is the career bucket?
Right, and, and when they do that,
even if they find something that gives them,
that feeling that they wanna have,
eventually that's gonna end.
You know, we know people bounce now from career to career
or job to job, to job so many times during the course of,
and the problem is like two years down the road,
when you move on to the next thing,
you'll never have understood what the underlying impulse
was that made you feel that way.
And your ability to replicate it in any future position
is left to chance.
So what I'm so much more interested in
is the deeper impulse,
because if you understand the deeper impulse,
then all of a sudden you get to dissociate it
from the constraint of a job or a title or an industry.
And you just get to scan the horizon and say,
what's gonna allow me to bring this impulse to bear
and all of a sudden, you know,
the possibilities become endless, ad that to me is magical.
Yeah, super powerful.
I mean, an example of that would be
the Maven who is attracted to a certain career
because it allows them to learn all kinds of things.
And then suddenly they, you know,
they become less sanguine about that career
and they don't know why.
And your example is that while they learned everything
that they needed to learn there wasn't,
there was no more avenue for deeper learning.
And without that, self-awareness that understanding of why,
you know, that stopped paying sort of
meaningful dividends for that person you're left confused.
Yeah, and I think like most of us never,
I don't know if you did this, but when I was a kid,
you know, we used to take these tests
that would sort of like,
you know, give you recommended careers and titles and jobs.
Which are, you know, on the one hand,
I'm not entirely can step because it gives you
a starting point.
But the challenge is most people use that list
as an all-inclusive constraint.
And then to me, you know,
it limits your life rather than expands it.
And I'm just not interested in that.
Yeah, in other words, you can be an accountant or a doctor
or a firefighter and be any one of these sparketypes
and find meaning in your career path,
by learning how to kind of be in a situation
that allows you to leverage or bring out the best
of those qualities in service of this job
or career that you're in.
Yeah, and like those, you know,
professions or titles that you've just mentioned,
you could look at every single one of those and say, okay,
you know, how could you be a doctor?
If you could be a doctor and you can be like
the maker impulse can find itself in the role of
medicine in so many different ways.
You could come up with a new surgical device
or a new process.
Yeah, like the scientists solving complex problems
in diagnostics, the essentialist,
organizing mass amounts of information, data charts,
so that you can really create clarity
and figure out what's happening.
I mean literally, every single one of these impulses
can show up in pretty much every job role or title.
If you understand how to express them
in intelligent and constructive way.
Right, which is why you have this recurring refrain
in the book that is like, don't explode your life
and quit your job.
Like, that's not what I'm saying here.
What I'm saying is develop a deeper understanding,
then figure out a way to approach your career or your job
with a new pair of glasses and try to figure out ways
within that construct to, you know,
bring out the best of what you have to offer.
Yeah, I mean, there tends to be a sort of pop psychology
edict that says, you know, like
figure out what you want to do.
And then anyone who disagrees with you
just like jettison them from your life.
If you're not happy doing what you're doing,
go turn in your resignation today, walk away from it.
Like, just go do the thing that, you know,
and a people have no idea what the underlying impulse is
that would let them do it,
which is going to be a massive problem in the next 36 months
as 20 to 50% of the people, you know,
do the same that they're calling the great resignation.
And then they're going to end up in the great regret
because they had no idea how to make a better decision.
But you know, it it's and the bigger reality
is that if you're 18 years old or 20 years old,
and the stakes are really low and you got your
life ahead of you and no responsibilities, awesome.
But if you're you or me,
or if you're in the middle of your life,
and you have people looking to you for stability
and support, and you have responsibilities,
you know, the notion that you would follow that advice to me
is so destructive.
Yeah, there's so much collateral damage.
So much collateral damage.
And we tend to dramatically overestimate the giddiness
that we'll feel when we do it and underestimate
the pain of the disruption that we caused.
And then when we land in it, we're like, oh, wow,
this is not what I thought was coming my way.
Because we didn't do it in a way
that was really intelligent.
I'm not entirely against like, you know,
like the big disruption.
But to me, it's the, it's the, the action of last resort
rather than the first step in.
Yeah, I don't know that I did it so intelligently.
You and me both, we have a history of blowing things up.
I definitely blew a few things up and there,
it was not without its collateral damage I can tell you.
100%, like there's been a lot of pain.
That's been like wrapped around
those big disruptive decisions.
And, you know, thankfully, you know,
we've been brought to our knees in various different ways
and, and learned from it and found a way back.
But you know, that most people will never make a move
if they think that that's what's gonna happen.
And also it just doesn't have to happen that way
for most people,
I think you and I also probably a bit more risk tolerant
than a lot of people.
And also, I mean, your case was also very different.
I mean, you are at a place physically, emotionally,
psychologically, and financially where
you were pretty wrecked.
Yeah, I was in a desperate state of mind.
I think, you know, making that decision,
do you leap when you leap, you know,
how much change are you, are you willing to tolerate?
Or what is, you know, rational in your given
set of circumstances brings up a conversation about
the psychology and nature of, of habit change.
You know, some people are draw a line in the sand
and you step over it and you never go back.
And some people work better with incremental change
and developing kind of some momentum,
very slow momentum over time.
It's a very case contigent situation.
100%, you know, we all have different tolerances
for uncertainty and for ambiguity.
And those tolerances changed dramatically
in relation to stakes.
You know, for most people, when the stakes are low,
you're pretty tolerant to uncomfort, to ambiguity,
to uncertainty, because there's really not much on the line.
You know, and that's why I think it's a lot easier,
even if you're a little bit more anxious around it.
It's a lot easier to make those calls when you're younger,
because for the most part, the stakes are lower
for most people and it's much more recoverable.
But for that again, to let the stakes tend to rise,
there's more on the line.
That doesn't mean that like, if it makes sense,
you don't make the big move, but you know,
there is a really strong relationship
between the level of stakes and your tolerance for ambiguity
and your decisions around that and anxiety at the same time.
I remember seeing some research when I was diving into book,
I wrote a number of years ago around uncertainty
and how we deal with it,
that showed that there is an inverse relationship
between tolerance for uncertainty or ambiguity
and creativity, cognitive problem solving
and insight based problem solving.
So basically the less tolerant you are for ambiguity,
the more anxious you become and the less functional
you become an able to actually solve your way out
of that moment in time.
And they didn't look at the stakes,
but my feeling is the missing variable in that
was the stakes because at the stakes are low nobody cares.
But when the stakes go high,
whether you should take incremental steps or blow it up,
becomes much more of an issue.
Is there any science, science, or,
or insight into how uncertainty tolerance correlates
with any of these various sparketypes?
I'm not aware of it because the body of work is so new.
This has been a weird book for me to write
because in the past I written books that were more like
what you, that the people that you described earlier,
where I'm synthesizing mass amounts of information,
but it's mostly other people's research.
And this is an entirely original body of work.
So we're literally, I mean, I'm doing,
I'm presenting to senior leadership
in global enterprises and I'm sort of like,
they're asking me all these questions and my answers is sort
of like, we're literally developing this in real time.
We're running the test in real time.
We're putting together cohorts in real time.
You know, we've got amazing validation around
the fact that these archetypes exist,
that this sparketype are real.
You've got 500,000 people moved through an assessment,
25 million data points that tell us no,
there's something really powerful
and mappable and valid here.
And now sort of like the next horizon is seeing how this
actually makes a difference in individual's lives.
And the stories are just kind of like mind blowing.
And now we're, we're moving into organizations and saying,
okay, from a leadership context,
from a team building context.
You know, how do we actually take these ideas and,
and allow people to organize themselves around work
that makes them come alive.
Because if we can crack that nut,
then leadership becomes a whole different game.
Yeah, I mean, once you,
if you take a whole team and you test them out,
then you realize where you can put these chess pieces
so that everybody is maximizing their potential
and the team can basically go to the next level
of what it's trying to accomplish.
Yeah, I mean, it's, it's what one person
who originally interviewed, who runs two companies
and has everybody in, in both companies are like,
do this work.
You know, she described to me as removing friction
from the process.
It's like, the friction just went away.
Because people weren't waking up trying to figure out
how do I do things that I don't wanna do.
There's always a part of that in every job.
Like you can't make it 100% yay.
But when you sort of like drop below a certain threshold
and most of the things, or the things that you innately
wake up in the morning, you know, like yearning to do
everything changes.
You know, the idea of motivation,
it's kind of off the table.
You know, like you don't have to motivate me
to eat dark chocolate every day.
Yeah, you have a chocolate fixation
like nobody I've ever met.
By the way I brought you chocolate, so.
Excuse me, oh, you did great.
I'll trade that for some (murmurs) chocolate.
It's LA chocolate, yeah.
Yeah, when I think about what I experienced,
when I wake up in the morning now,
versus what I used to feel like when I was working
in a law firm, it's I, I have a hard time even like,
relating to that, other than the PTSD
that's associated with that, like,
you had a different relationship with the law.
Like you enjoyed it more than I did, but man, you know,
talk about like a guy who was on the wrong path
and didn't know it and didn't know how to get out of it
and didn't have any tools for understanding
how to make the most of it while I was in it.
All right, so let me ask you a question now.
You've done this, the assessment?
I have, but we should say like,
you answer a series of quite the sparketype test,
you answer a series of questions,
which I felt like you kept asking me the same question.
Over and over and over, you feel like
why do you keep asking the same thing?
So what's fascinating about it.
So, so we did, we took a year to develop this assessment.
I'm gonna ask you how you came up with the question.
Yeah, it can't just be like an idea in my mind or,
you know, I didn't want you to just say, okay,
let me read this 10 descriptions and yeah figure out
what feels right to me because there's gonna be
a whole bunch of bias in there and there's no way
to remove bias from it.
But a lot of people would be like, oh, I want to be this.
So they'll say on that.
It's really hard to when I was answering them, like,
it's the person I aspire to be like, what is,
what is really true here.
And those are the instructions that we give
in the beginning of the assessment.
It's like, don't take this because like, you know, you know,
because that's who you think you wanna be, or you should be.
Answer for who you are.
Holding yourself out to be.
Right, like, cause it becomes useless at that point,
you know, take this like answer honestly to these 50
or so questions and, and you know,
and then you get assigned your types.
And the, the thought that went into the prompts
for that assessment were really based
around these five domains.
It, how do we create prompts and questions
that relate back to these different things?
So what's interesting is that you,
you kind of feel like didn't, I just answer that question,
but actually it's, it there's slightly different nuances
and each one of them that register back
to a different state.
But, but your brain doesn't necessarily consciously process
that nuance, but when you answer it, usually it does.
We did a smaller scale, sort of a preliminary
follow-up study on, on validation for this.
We were looking for validation and also
for correlations to these five states.
And we, in that we have to go a lot deeper
into this data now and do probably a much larger scale study
but we saw a 93% validation rate for people's types.
Reporting that there types that were assigned
were either extremely to very accurate for them.
And then really high correlations with people saying,
you know, the more you do the work of your sparketype,
the more I'm going to say that like I matter,
and the work that I'm doing is deeply meaningful.
Like all those different things,
even though it may feel a little bit like,
are they just asking me the same things over and over again?
And they're also not everybody takes the same assessment,
which people are sometimes confused about.
So the algorithm for this is actually a little bit more
complex than just simple addition
and 10 different categories.
Wait what do you mean not everyone takes the same test?
So the assessment actually tracks
how you're differentiating your answers and potentially.
Oh, and at a certain point,
it then leads you down a different, questions?
Yeah, the algorithm may dynamically add up
to three additional questions,
which are designed to force discernment.
So if it senses that you're not actually
making really thoughtful choices and just answering
a little bit where you're not
really teasing out differentiation,
it will actually prompt you to think a little bit harder.
And we've been told that some like when people get those
additional questions at the end, they can be thorny.
But that's intentional.
Because again, the last thing I want to do is create a tool
and a body of work that's interesting, but not useful.
And so I want something that resonates,
that has a really strong level of people.
Like it goes back to what we were talking about earlier.
Like I'd want you to actually like finish this experience
and, and think to yourself, I feel seen this is right.
And this is valuable.
Like I've just learned something about the way
that I can now step back into the world and make decisions
that are maybe like a little bit better informed
for me moving forward.
And just to be clear, one, one of the questions is not,
what's the date of your birth and what time were you born?
I love the Enneagram, but this is different.
It's totally different, and I love the Enneagram also.
And, and people often ask us, you know,
we're in the second iteration of the assessment now,
like we expanded the algorithm to now include that,
that anti-spam sparketype that I referenced.
So people are always asking me like,
how is this the same or different from the Enneagram
StrengthsFinder via strengths?
You like disc and Myers-Briggs
and all these different things.
It's, it's one that Julie caught.
Yeah, actually that recently landed 'cause there's
a bunch of people asked me about it
and how it related to it.
And it's been interesting.
Cause I think they all offer pieces of the puzzle.
So there's some overlap with, with certain ones
but the, sparketype is, it's a much more focused tool.
Like I'm only answering one question.
I'm not speaking to your personality profile.
I'm not speaking to your relational styles.
And not speaking to all these, I'm not giving you
a broad spectrum of all the ways that you exist
in the world.
What I'm speaking to is a single thing,
which is the fundamental impulse for effort
that makes you feel alive, right.
And then around that, like in the book, then I,
I explain a whole bunch of observations about how
people with that impulse tend to show up in the world.
But the fundamental thing that I'm looking at
is just this one thing is that impulse,
because if we can dial that in, you know,
like going all the way back to that question,
what should I do with my life?
There are a lot of answers to that.
And there are a lot of layers to peel with that,
you know, like human potential onion.
But if we can figure out, like in the context of work,
the thing that we invest a third of our life doing,
whether it's the thing we get paid for, or not.
Like I said, I consider work maybe it's your job.
Maybe it's your role as a caregiver or parent
or a companion or a volunteer, whatever it may be.
It's a thing you invest your energy in,
under a persistent basis for years and decades.
If we can figure out how to spend that time
in a way that's deeply nursing
and fully expressing ourselves,
how is that gonna change us as human beings?
How is it gonna change our relationships,
how is it gonna change work, how's it gonna change society?
Like we need human beings who are existing
in that state now more than ever,
because we are in a place where we need people
to be at their best.
Yeah, on top of which there is this,
you know epidemic of dissatisfaction in peoples,
not just in their professions, careers, jobs,
but also in other facets of their life,
in which they are investing a lot of time and energy.
Yeah, it's super pervasive.
And the one thing that we know is as we enter this time
of emergence, we're entering a moment
of existential questioning that I don't think either of us
have seen in our lifetime.
You know, it happens after major wars.
It happened for me after 911,
especially as a New Yorker, but at a scale
that has happening now where nobody is left
out of this questioning.
And why do you think that is?
Do you think that that is happening now because of the
confluence of COVID and the political climate
and what social media is doing to us and climate change?
Like it's the combination of all of these,
existential things that we are dealing with.
I think it's a confluence of a global health crisis
that made it clear to so many people, to most people
that nobody gets to just like sign away a document
or pay the way out of this,
that maybe that's not entirely true privilege
has definitely played a role in outcomes and, and access,
but that we're all affected in a really profound way,
the complete decimation of the structure of work,
as we know it, and everybody, so many people,
you know, like there's, there's class differences
and work now there's, you know, like remote work now,
there's all sorts of things where work has been turned
upside down in so many ways that the ground
beneath us from a work context
has been completely destroyed.
Including including the social power dynamic.
Absolutely, and then at the, at the same time, you know,
we've got like deep questioning and disruption
and change thinking on big societal questions
that has had that happened for a really, really long time.
It's been really interesting to see how you've been
approaching that in the context of the conversations
you've been having here also.
And so I think we're in this state of, like you said,
it's the confluence of disruption in nearly every part
of our lives that gives us a feeling of groundlessness
that's forcing us to question, what do we want
the next season of our lives to look like and to feel like,
and a lot of people are starting to realize
that they don't entirely know what the answer is,
but what they do know is not the way I've been feeling.
And the gift of course is the opportunity to reframe that.
Yeah, I mean, to take it and say, okay, so, you know,
if that's the negative, what's the negative to the negative,
what's the positive, like, what do I want to create
in this next season, moving forward?
How do I wanna move into it?
How do I want to feel?
You know, like how do I want to contribute
to my life to lives of those around us?
What matters to me?
You know, it's all, it's all tied up.
And I think the earlier crisis, 911,
a certain group of people felt that,
2008, 2009, the financial collapse a certain group of people
felt that some of the major global wars
and crisises in generations that generally
were different from ours, felt that.
This in my mind is one of the first times where
it's so many people are feeling it
on so many different parts of their lives simultaneously.
And at the same time, because the structure of work
was blown up and a lot of people are realizing, okay,
it was really tough to figure this out in the beginning,
but now I kinda like it.
I don't want to go back and a massively burned out
from trying to actually sustain myself.
I don't want to go back to the way things were.
And like you said, the question then becomes,
okay, so then, then where are we going from here?
Right, and are sparked at just the right moment, right.
The divine timing here is unbelievable for you
given the fact that you've been working on this for a year,
I'm sure you would have preferred that it went out
a year ago.
I would have, I would have preferred
that there was no need for this work whatsoever.
Like I said, I kind of willfully go into this.
I was kind of hoping there were other answers,
but you know, it is not lost on me.
The fact that I have spent a lot of time in the world of
wellbeing, of fitness, of yoga, spirituality,
philosophy, and science.
And despite the fact that there's so much wisdom out there,
the human condition remains so fiercely broken.
And our satisfaction with who we are as individuals
and the way that we interact,
and the way that we live in the planet
is still so unsatisfying on so many levels.
Even when you look at people who are objectively
from the outside, looking in living good lives,
I just keep wondering what we're missing.
You know, and, and if there's even like
a hint of a hint of a hint of an answer
that I can help provide that matters to,
you know, like enough people, I'm all in on that.
Yeah, it's beautiful, man.
It's a beautiful act of service.
So I'm gonna ask you, what do you think
my primary and secondary sparketypes are?
I knew you were gonna do this.
Of course, everybody, who's gonna interview you
will ask you this.
I have been around tables, rows, and you know,
like running here, like consulting,
like three-day mastermind,
consulting sessions with eight people.
And the end of it they'd be like,
okay, she knows really well now, like tell us.
Everybody that you must think though,
after being so steeped in this, that every person you meet,
you run a calculation and go, I bet that person's a this.
I'm curious about it.
But like I said earlier, what I have learned is that
what you see on the surface is not always,
or necessarily the deeper impulse that's being expressed.
It may just be what people are using to cope
and live a comfortable life that feels safe.
For you let's see.
What would I think you are.
It's interesting, I'll preface this
while you're thinking about it.
I would have thought that you, I'm not surprised
that your primary sparketype is maker,
but I would have thought your secondary
would have been nurturer or advisor.
But then when I, when I read about the scientist
and your explanation of that, it makes sense like that fits
no, but it feels like it could have easily been
one of those other things as well.
Yeah, and like, if I broke out all my raw scores,
like, I wouldn't be surprised if the nurturer
is more towards like the stronger side of, of impulses,
but it's not.
I literally wake up, I was a kid when I was
seven, eight, nine years old, grew up in a small town.
I would on a Sunday morning, I would beg one of my parents
like get the old Chevy blazer, drive me to the town dump,
crack, open the tailgate, throwing a bunch of like,
like discarded bicycles and parts, go back home,
stay in the garage and duct tape them together
to build Franken bikes, to ride around the neighborhood.
Like, I, this has been an impulse that has been with me
for as long as I've been conscious.
That it's like crystal clear that that's me.
The scientist yeah.
I think it's, it's there in a really strong way.
And it's been of service to the maker me
in a really powerful way and then nurture, yeah,
I care about people, but apparently the figure,
it out thing shows up stronger.
And I can actually validate that in terms of like
what I'm more called to do.
I get it.
For you, you're gonna put me on the spot.
I feel like the nurturer is really strong in you also.
I don't know if I'd say that's your primary though.
I could see the scientist in you also,
I can see so many of that, you can just tell me.
All right, I'll tell you.
Primary is maker, shadow is performer.
I was gonna say maker.
The performer, I bet surprises you or does it not?
A little bit, but not, not really.
You know, I think, I think it all sort of, you know,
one of the things you talk about in the book is
people discover this within themselves either
because they get plugged into the right thing
at an early age and just thrive in it,
or they experiment and tinker over the course of their
lifetime and ultimately kind of find themselves
in a situation and, and where it fits.
And for me, you know, we, this whole conversation
kind of began with me talking about my dissatisfaction
with being a lawyer.
My, my anti-spam sparketype is advocate, right.
So the, you know, a lawyer is an advocate,
like I was not.
Those validated it pretty powerful.
Yeah, exactly.
I wouldn't, and now I'm in a situation
where I do make things, but I don't make things
like I'm not building go-carts or fixing cars or,
you know, using my hands.
It's a, it's a more ephemeral version of,
of making what you also talk about in the book.
It doesn't have to be a three-dimensional object.
It can be, you know, curating a conversation
that's meaningful for other people is making something
on some level, the performer part.
Yeah, like I loved being like I did tons of plays
when I was a kid, which is weird
because I'm also introverted.
And I enjoy the fact that we have a studio
and we're doing this for YouTube as well.
So there is a performative aspect of that,
that I find satisfying.
And yet at the same time, like I'm deeply
you know, afraid of getting up on stages,
even though I do public speaking.
Like, it's not like I'm not this, you know,
Gallant extrovert that just gets a lot of energy from that.
It's actually taxing for me,
even though I'd find it satisfying.
Yeah, that's actually fascinating.
So the maker I can completely see now
because yeah, since I've known you,
you've created so many different things,
whether it's these experiences,
the media that wraps around it,
books, moments, they're like physical objects,
theorial objects, digital experiences, events.
It's all about the idea of imagining something
and then making it real.
So I can see that in so many different ways.
The performer, I didn't know about your past,
but that's really interesting to me.
And that what you brought up about the relationship
between the performer impulse and your social orientation
is interesting too, because you're not alone in that.
There tends to be this association that says, like,
if you had this performer impulse,
like your impulse is to animate
and alive in moments, experiences and interactions
that you've got to be a raging extrovert.
There's almost no relationship to that whatsoever.
Similar to you, like I love being on stage to keynote
for an hour.
And then I'm looking for the stage door to exit
the back of the theater because I'm an introvert
and I need to recharge by being away from people.
And so, you know, the fact that you actually
can really dive into a moment or experience
and be immersed in it and bring it to life
when you're in it.
But then you like need to pull back a little bit
because your social wiring requires you to refuel
by being away from that for a bit.
It's an interesting dynamic that I think some people
have trouble navigating or understanding how they could be,
how they could exist in harmony.
But in fact, you see that pretty regularly.
Right, you would assume that there would be some type
of symmetry that correlates introversion and extroversion
to these various marketize.
But in fact, that's not the case it's completely decoupled.
And you can be, you know, on any number of points
along that spectrum, irrespective of what
your sparketype is.
Yeah, 100%, we recently, I had a conversation
with Elaine Aron who is sort of like the primary researcher
and the creator of the phrase, highly sensitive person.
She identified it first as a trait 25, 26 years ago,
and has done all the seminal research on
highly sensitive people.
And in the conversation, she said something to me,
which I'd never heard before,
because I identify myself as a highly sensitive person.
I process differently, you know like in social environments,
I operate differently.
But she said you can be highly sensitive
and also high sensation, which means you also seek
highly stimulating high sensation experiences,
which seems counterintuitive on the surface.
But she's like, it's actually not that uncommon
because I know that that's me.
Like I am, I'm definitely more on the introverted
side of the spectrum.
I love to be in super high stakes situations
in front of a lot of people for a moment in time.
And then I need to step back from it.
I'd love to like go and, you know,
like I would go mountain biking,
like in a past life or rock climbing.
I like to do these super high sensation experiences
sometimes alone or with a bunch of people.
So it's interesting to see that,
you know, we are complex beings.
Right, and yet there is, you know, a lattice work,
a framework to help us understand ourselves.
And, and as, you know,
as much as we're all beautiful snowflakes,
there's a way of making sense of certain pillars that can,
we can use as mental models to make better decisions
about our laws.
And I think that's what it comes down to,
like how do we know ourselves better
and make better decisions so we can take better actions?
You know, if we can figure out pieces of that puzzle,
everything gets a lot easier and better.
The other interesting thing in the book is,
is the fact that with each of these archetypes,
you, you sort of say, okay, here's how,
here's how you can leverage this to plug in to your
specific career or job, or think about,
you know, how you approach your life.
But here are the pitfalls.
Like if you're this, if you fall into this category,
you know, these people also struggle with X, Y, and Z,
and you should be aware of that and look out for it.
Yeah, and that's where you move from impulse to archetype.
That's the distinction.
The impulse is the fundamental impulse
to work or to exert effort in a particular way.
And the archetype is the tendencies,
the preferences and the behaviors that,
that often wrap around it.
They are not universal for everybody,
but there are some pretty common patterns.
And a lot of those involve dark holes, places where
people stumble challenges, you know, like for example,
the scientist, very often, you see a lot of scientists
latch on to a problem that is thorny and complex
and obsessive really immerse themselves in it
where they cannot let go of it.
And they may end up figuring out something incredible,
you know, and getting an answer that is really
like life changing, paradigm changing, maybe world shaking.
But they lose themselves and their lives
and their relationships and their health
and their wellbeing in the process.
Because they're following the impulse.
So it's really important to understand
that this is something to look out for
because life exists beyond just this impulse.
Yeah, lack of control is another one that shows up quite
a bit, right.
Like if you're a maker, you just want to do your thing
and you want everybody to just leave you alone, right.
But as you're, if you're in an organization
and there's a team aspect to all of this,
it gets complicated quickly.
Yeah, and, and part of that is also
because one of those five components that I talk about,
like, you know, when we say effort
that makes you come alive is flow.
And flow is a highly absorptive, absorptive, absorptive.
A flow is a highly absorbed state.
Absorptive, I don't know.
Flow is a state in which
you become a highly absorbed, right.
Which means you lose track of self, you lose track of time,
you lose track of your environment.
So you, you know, it's a healthy thing
to set circuit breakers and boundaries around that.
Because like I said, you know,
like this is one part of life, but it is not life itself.
What if you do the test,
you get the result and you're like, God damn it.
I don't wanna be that person.
It happens.
Yeah.
We have, like, I've seen people, I'm like,
why is this email on there three times?
It's like.
Oh, they re-took it a bunch of times?
Trying to get it that kind of trying to,
trying to get it and figure out the answer
so they can get a different result.
Or we've just had people email and they're like,
or tell me personally at an event or something.
And like, I really want it to be something else.
Like the thing that comes to mind immediately was
somebody was their primary, it was an essentialist.
And there came to me and said, you now
I really, really want it to be a warrior because it seems,
and warrior is about gathering and leading.
Because it seems so like much just fiercer
and more like respected.
And like, I want to be seen as that person in the world.
And I think it's kind of funny because, you know,
and I had this reframe, I said, I totally get that.
You know, maybe like, you know,
essentialist sounds a little boring to you,
but here's the deal.
The work that you do is actually amongst
the most loathed work by all the other nine types
and appreciated by all the other nine types
because they so don't want to do it.
You're one of the most indispensable people on the planet.
And when people realize what you're capable of,
you're exalted and desired in any place that you go,
you are the glue that makes everything else work.
Yeah, put you in high demand.
But here's the thing, like,
how do you parse that aspiration?
Like that person says, I wanna be this,
my fundamental disposition is different from that,
but who are you to say, you can't be that thing
that you wanna be.
Or if you're chasing that thing that you wanna be,
you're, you're going down a blind alley.
Yeah, what I would say to them is run the experiment.
Like who am I to actually tell you what your truth is?
And I think that's actually a really good thing to bring up,
is whether it's a sparketype,
whether it's any of the other major assessments
that are available to people today,
they're by definition, blunt instruments.
You know, we've got really good data on, on ours.
And a lot of people who've now taken it.
So we have big data on it.
But at the same time, you know, at the end of the day,
you know, you, if you're really paying attention,
and if you're somebody who's done
the work to be, self-aware, you're going to have a sense
for whether this is valid or not.
And if everything inside of you screams.
So, so I think it's important to make a distinction
that says, do you feel like this is wrong?
Or do you just like yearn to be something else,
simply because, you know, like you,
you perceive that the world will perceive you
differently if you are.
And if you truly believe that something's off,
then I think with any assessment,
then you got to kind of reflect on that and go with your gut
and ask yourself the big questions.
But if you also, if you, if you basically just say yourself,
I want to be seen that someone different in the world,
I want to be seeing this a different type of person
in the world, then I think you got a question why that is.
Yeah, genesis of that desire.
Is that being driven by social factors
or the way that you were parented or whatever reinforcements
you've experienced over the course of your life.
Right, because every one of these different impulses
and sparketypes has profound value to you and to the world.
There's none that's just sort of like, oh,
a lesser than type of thing.
So if something inside of you says, but,
but I really want to be something else then,
you know, like, yeah, you sort of,
the work is to deconstruct that where's that coming from,
you know, like why, why do I perceive this thing
that is inside of me that yearns to make me work
as lesser than in some way, shape or form.
It's a heavy thing, man, that you shoulder quite
a bit of responsibility because somebody takes this test.
It says, okay, here's, here's you kind of fall
into these categories that becomes
self determinative in certain ways.
Because if it, if then that's the lens
through which you're perceiving the world,
I am this kind of person you're gonna make decisions
based on that, like, it's not a small thing.
Yeah, and that's something that I've grappled with.
And it's probably one of the reasons
why initially I resisted doing this work.
And it's also one of the reasons why, like I said,
what I just said, which is that at the end of the day,
this is a tool to help you.
But the tool alone is not determinative of you,
your own self-awareness your own self knowledge,
your understanding of who you are in the world.
If you do the work, it's a tool to increase your own level
of self awareness and self knowledge.
It is not the ultimate tool and the ultimate arbiter.
So I'm a huge fan of actually looking at this as one tool
in a toolbox of a whole bunch of other tools,
practices pass explorations.
It doesn't supplant anything else.
It's just another thing to give you a bit more insight
if it feels right, if it feels resonant well with it,
if it doesn't, don't.
You know, don't supplant your own inner voice.
And that, and I say that in the context,
not just of the sparketype, but of everything,
of any, one of those tools in your toolbox.
You know, you have to ask the big questions.
Am I resisting it because of some sense of shame
or other, social contract or other pathology?
Sure, what is the locus of that inner voice,
is it corrupted or influence?
Of course it is.
It's, it's influenced by your life experience, but you know,
there's a lot of work that goes into self-understanding.
So that, that inner voice can be trusted
as intrinsic versus reactive.
Yeah, the, the thing that tends to that I look at a lot is
when you, if you take the assessment and then like,
if you look the more detailed information
that's in the book, how does it land?
Like, do you literally, I, what I look for
is an embodied response.
If it's cognitively interesting to you,
I'm not entirely sure that we got it.
If you, if, if there is a felt response to this,
but there's something visceral where like your body is
tingling or something in you is saying, oh, hell yeah.
Like, like going all the way back to the beginning
of the conversation, where if, if you,
if you do this and there's something inside of you,
your whole body screams, this is me.
I feel seen like, this is so true to me.
And the way that I've existed in the world.
Then I think that, that's what I love for.
The single biggest response that we see,
if we're going to isolate a word
that people share in response to this work,
it's not that they've learned something new it's validation
that they've actually known this their lives.
Right, and you're providing a construct
or a language for that.
It's a key that goes into a lock.
And that key turns in a fluid way,
and it is an emotional thing.
You're like, that's what I am, I knew it all along.
Yeah.
Now I can more deeply understand my motivation.
Or this thing that I felt for most of my life,
but stifled or put away, because for any number of reasons,
I learned that it was inappropriate to lead with that
or show it, oh, this actually matters.
This actually is important.
Like, I, can't the weight of not living into this
is not worth the pain that it's causing anymore.
Do you have a sense of, of the archetypes
emanating more from nature is nurture,
does nurture play a part in this?
Are they malleable over time?
Do do, do these types change.
I mean, you know, I'm sure if you had decades
of performing this test and research,
you'd have a better sense of that, but what's your gut.
Yeah, so that last point was, was spot on.
It's nearly impossible to enter that question
from an actual data-driven standpoint,
because we would literally need to trap people.
You know, like from birth through the time
that they took the assessment to see whether
state things have stayed consistent,
similar to all the other major indexes.
But a number of the prompts and the assessment
have actually designed to be long-term reflective
and have people answer from a place of what
has been a consistent through line that I can identify
in my entire life that has seemed to like show up
and be there the whole time.
The other thing is that intuitively
and anecdotally we've talked, I talked to a lot of people
now I've like done a lot of story-based
and interview based research.
And the consistent thread really does seem to be that this,
whether it's, you know like genetic,
whether it's behavioral, whether it's environmental,
whether it's spiritually endowed, I honestly don't know.
Maybe it's some blend of all of those,
but it does tend to touch down pretty early in life.
And in my mind, from what I've seen,
stay fairly consistent, barring some major,
major disruption in a person's psyche or brain
or physiology on the level that literally would rewire them,
which can happen.
You know, if somebody has a psychotic break,
their brain is not different.
The same as it was before, somebody has traumatic brain
industry, the injury, the brain is different.
But what we've seen is that I do believe
that it stays relatively steady state,
but that has a really interesting, you know,
like compliment to it, which is,
you know, can it change over time?
Well, what if I take the assessment once,
and then two years later, I take it and maybe my primary,
my shadow have switched or there's a different answer.
Does that mean that my sparketype of switch?
In my mind, that's unlikely.
I think what's much more likely to happen is that the
primary constraint to your ability to answer these questions
in a really articulate self-aware way has changed.
So any one of these assessments are limited by the depth
and quality of your experiences
and your level of self-awareness.
That can change in a major way.
Guaranteed over the last two years,
people have experienced things in that lies that force them
into work relationships, scenarios, circumstances
that they've never experienced before.
And a lot of people have become much more self-aware
of how they feel about a lot of different things.
So if they return to it, they may actually bring
that level of greater depth and self-awareness
to responding in a way that's probably more informed.
Yeah, that's, that's, that's a very good point.
That's interesting.
Yeah, because if you're, if you're not self-aware
and you're, you're living in some state of, of denial,
your responses to these questions are gonna reflect,
you know, the person that you believe yourself to be,
not necessarily the person that you actually are.
Yeah, which leads to a useless outcome,
you know, and that's just, that's not what this is about.
Yeah, but anybody who's a parent,
especially if you have more than one child you,
you, you learn pretty, pretty immediately.
Like kids come out the way they are.
And of course, nurture plays a huge part in it.
But constitutionally, you could see the differences
like immediately, and those are differences
that remain constant throughout their life.
Yeah, I mean, it's funny because there's,
I feel like culturally, we hate the idea
that anything about us is fixed.
That anything about us is not susceptible
to change over time.
And yet, you know, like Moz or Hazel,
they're not changing.
You know, there are,
there is a lot about us physiologically.
That is what it is that may change over
time with gene therapy and other stuff.
But right now there are certain things that we say, yeah,
that's sort of like, it is what it is.
But when we talk about psychology or brain or,
or a growth or abilities or capabilities,
we hate the notion that we are not
entirely evolutionary beings.
We reject that outright simply because
we don't want to feel like, you know,
like there's a certain thing about us
that will always be a certain way.
And yet it's not necessarily a bad thing, you know.
And, and we are a certain way.
And in certain domains of life,
the word trait exists for a reason, you know,
trait versus state they're different things.
So you know, in the context of the sparketypes,
can I give you a hundred percent data-based answer
that says it's 100% fixed.
It won't change over time.
This is a trait I can't, because the data just isn't there
and it will, you will never be able to actually prove
that through data, but from everything that I'm seeing,
it does look like it stays relatively
the same throughout life.
And like you said, any parent knows, like,
like kids touched down with a certain wiring that,
that you can put a much track to their entire life.
It doesn't matter what you do.
Right, you know, and some of it is malleable,
but I think some of it isn't.
You know, I brought up Elaine Aron
earlier who identified this thing
called highly sensitive person.
She identifies that as a trait,
it's not something you grow out of or evolve yourself,
you know, like, like out of you can learn skills
to allow yourself to cope and be in the world
and a much more comfortable and easeful
and constructive way.
And really understand the gorgeousness
and the value of that trait.
But it doesn't necessarily mean that you've changed
the underlying, like code.
Sure, I loved how you talk about
how we kind of innately find our way into situations
in which, you know, our, our archetypes
will kind of match up with our environment.
And that happens as I talked about earlier,
either through, you know, sort of luck
of getting plugged into something at an early age
or through a process of, of experimentation over time.
And, and my sense is that the,
the extent of that fit or how well, you know, that fit
happens for somebody is going to calibrate with their risk
tolerance, with their relationship to failure,
you know, to all of these things, kind of,
it reminds me a little bit of,
of David Epstein's book Range, in that, you know,
you've got to try a bunch of different stuff
until you find that magical situation where your archetypes,
your sparketypes kind of match with the environment.
Yeah, and I loved that book.
I loved the way that his brain works.
Yeah, don't specialize too quickly,
like keep running the experiments.
And, and we've used the word experiment
to a whole bunch of times in this conversation.
And I look at life as basically like my job
is to just keep running experiments and,
and make my primary metric for those experiments,
not success or failure, but simply learning.
And, and also running smaller scale,
lower stakes experiments before I commit to a bigger scale,
higher stakes project or endeavor or company.
I haven't always done,
but I'm at a point in my life now where I'm kind of like
before I, yes, say yes to something big and scary
and high stakes, I want to run a series of experiments.
So I look at life almost entirely as a series of,
how can I get out of my head?
How can I get out of assumption land,
and how can I just run an experiment on any particular thing
that will give me more intel,
validate or invalidate my assumptions,
and then a better central what to say yes or no to.
And that's one way to figure out your sparketype, you don't
have to, you don't necessarily have to take the assessment.
The assessment is just hopefully a much faster,
shorter path to discovering it then years
of potential experimentation.
And the truth is most people
don't live their lives that way.
Most people live their lives much more
with, with a lower sense of directionality agency.
Sure, and kind of out of sheer, but out of sheer sort of,
you know, autopilot, defense mechanisms,
most people find them in some, you know version,
even if it's a low grade version of a situation that allows
their, their sparketype to manifest in some way.
Yeah, and, and also like more broadly speaking,
some people have life situations that allow them
more freedom to run experiments and other people don't.
I mean, if you are like in a circumstance where you like,
you've got, you know, a lot of people looking to you
to support them, you know, where you're working three jobs
to put food on the table.
Yeah, there, there are a lot,
there are certain life circumstances.
I think it's important to acknowledge control our ability.
Your, sparketype is an indulgent luxury.
Yeah, I think running, devoting yourself to running
a series of experiments, like as a way to figure this out,
assumes that you have the time and the ability to do that.
Not everybody does, you know, which again is why,
like I'm trying to build tools that are accessible
and available to everybody that they can at least try
and help shortcut some of that process.
And yet, you know, for anybody who is in a job,
taking this assessment, reading this book
gives you a broader understanding
of kind of how you function.
So within the construct of that job,
perhaps there are ways in which you can be better
at your job or more fulfilled in that capacity.
And ultimately, you know a happier
more purpose-driven person, if you can find a way
to bring those personality traits to life
and channel them in that construct.
100%, you know this is not about like figuring out
what the next job that you're moving to is,
if that ends up being the choice that you make, fine.
But like fundamentally that the steps before that are
it's about knowing yourself on a deeper level.
So you can understand how can I show up differently,
how can I understand what to say yes or no to,
how can I potentially expand beyond the job description,
how can I add nuance and more meaning and context to what
I'm doing in a way that I experience it differently.
And that fills me up more.
Yeah, I can just tell you, after taking the assessment
and reading the better part of the book,
and then reflecting on decisions that I've made big and
small over many years to kind of arrive in this place,
it's amazing the extent to which
I made these decisions unconsciously,
like there were unconscious drivers that ultimately, and,
and very non-linearly and inelegantly kind of nudged me
into this direction that we're in.
They're unconscious motivators, like, but,
but then developing a conscious awareness of them
allows you to then be that much more purposeful
and directed in those decisions that you make.
Yeah, and developing a conscious awareness
and then definitely does.
And spending less time to get to that place.
I'm a huge fan, like in the heart of it,
okay, I'm not in New York anymore,
but I live in New York pace of life
for the vast majority of my life.
And the idea of like waiting online for anything
is horrifying to me still, even though like I live out
in the mountains and stuff like that.
As an entrepreneur, I want it to happen yesterday.
You know, as somebody who is in ridiculously
future oriented, I just want it to show up now.
You know, should to the extent that yes,
if you want to take sort of like the laborious way
or the long-term way, that that's fine,
but I'm kind of wired for speed, which is one of the reasons
why I meditate every day as like a counterbalance to that.
And that line make things that move people.
It's not just about me.
You know, and a lot of people are in a place in life
where they don't have the time, the bandwidth,
the resources, the interest to spend a lot of time
going deep into this.
And if I can offer anything that helps get people
to a place of self-awareness faster, I want to.
I think that's a good place to end it.
I think he stuck the landing.
How do you feel?
I feel good.
Yeah.
How do you feel?
I feel great, man.
I'm just happy to be with you.
Yeah, I know.
It's like, can we take a hug break?
We will, will we hug before or hug after?
For sure, I love you.
I love you too, man.
I'm proud of you with this new book.
I think it's gonna help a lot of people.
Thanks, I hope so.
Yeah, so everybody check it out, it's called Sparked.
It's available everywhere.
It hits bookstores September 16th?
September 21st.
21st.
Yeah.
Patronize your favorite independent bookseller.
Short of that, it's available in all the normal places
and you can find Jonathan at the good life project,
Jonathanfields.com.
Where else do you want people to go?
That sounds good to me.
Good to know, yeah.
You're so low key about that.
And where are you off to next in your nomadic adventures?
I'm hanging out in California for a bit.
And then off to Brooklyn and then to New Orleans,
then to Brooklyn then to Napa then to Boulder.
Wow.
Where like Boulder is sorta like the, the quote residence.
Yeah, it's, it's where we're based out of.
Yeah, good for you man.
Awesome.
You seem happy, you seem healthy, you look great.
I feel good.
Yeah, and I'm proud to be your friend.
Thanks.
Cool, man.
Well, we'll continue this conversation, peace.
Plans.
(upbeat music)